yo what's up is Kevin Bozeman aka rap
name cake bizzle about to drop some bars
here in Nashville I know you guys went
back to do your thing I was I was the
one in there I set it all off I'm the
pioneer I'm the trendsetter I'm sure you
guys had your little [ __ ] wraps your
little thing going on but it's gonna be
hard to top of what I did
brothers yeah you know what it is free
sound TT you wanna be me okay
it was straight fire what's up you I'm
not so super caramel dropping hot bars
in from strangers I'm I'm definitely
confident about actually watch strangers
to watch me flow with a magnificent
rhythm and pace you think about you get
bars form you always get bars man I got
barkos I got I go to bars I got prison
bars
I got xanax bars I got bars I got
security bars to keep you from stealing
my new phone from my car if it's open of
a walk writing and it just stops slow
yeah
I'll make a beeline dude somebody in
there no it doesn't look like it even
really hurt Kevin spit that much already
sure what I'm gonna do but it's let's go
you don't really
he doesn't really flow around us maybe
he's got a secret bars yo it's the K
bizzle dropping sizzles mat hits Anthony
Rizzo
it ain't no joke I'm full of egg yolks
when I need a protein I'm a dope fiend
Starbucks 5 shots so success expressive
eyes to the busy fellow white chocolate
mocha I get rocks I get hot I drop game
of spitting it boss superstar really
good I felt like when I do break I want
I want everyone outside everyone a copy
of my album we did
we can battle right now if you want I
mean we can go toe-to-toe I never had
different dads
oh I never had different more lyrics
than more hooks isn't that work double
what I'm paying for
[Laughter]
I never had different dads
what I like them just trying to get into
the booth and speak from my heart you
know work on my aunt lives in Nashville
dippin dots I never had him the kids
seemed like they really liked him
I see him a lot I never tried them I
don't want no [ __ ] dippin dots
it was amazing to get that off my chest
thank diamond Records for the
opportunity and the creative space to be
myself think of it you guys are great to
have you you know that was the first
time we ever cut refuse yeah sounds like
it
step down camera flashing on national
water water dripping I'm splashing on
Matt's back one top to my Breland eggs
upstate birth gang bang Burt